wenn sie sagen sie brauchen kampfpanzer
dann sollten wir das ernst nehmen
sollten ihnen das liefern sie haben in
den letzten monaten bewiesen wehren uns
ja die anfangs diskussion im februar sie
haben in den letzten monaten bewiesen
dass sie genau wissen was sie brauchen
um ihre leben zu schützen und sich zu
verteidigen waffen ja panzer nein das
ist die antwort der bundesregierung auf
alle panzer anfragen aus der ukraine
seit monaten
doch jetzt machten sie druck die
deutsche eu kommissionschef in ursula
von der leyen ich finde ganz wichtig die
ukraine beweisen ja dass sie wenn sie
die richtigen militärischen mittel haben
sich verteidigen können und sie kämpfen
diesen kampf für uns alle das ist der
kampf dass die demokratie siegt und die
autokratie verliert es ist definitiv ein
einmaliger politischer vorgang dass die
eu kommissionspräsidenten in einem
interview sagt die eu staaten sollen
kampfpanzer liefern das hat es noch
nicht gegeben